got like a Pillsbury dough face kind of
you know
bro got it what's up we're here in Times
Square and we're gonna see uh what
people think the meanest thing that
anyone's ever said about me is the
actual meanest thing anyone's ever said
about me is
because I guess they win a prize if they
don't I guess all my feelings will be
heard what do you think the meanest
thing that someone's commented on one of
my videos is
haircut yeah taper and you grab a little
curl on top okay so we all agree it's
it's my haircut and what do you think
the meanest thing someone said about me
is
arrogant well that's like the first word
like policing my head when you see me
the first word that pops up in your head
is arrogant
I'm one of the best looking people
you've ever seen too right exactly your
shoes
match
probably defeat I'm not gonna lie
probably
he could add a nice beard I wish that I
could do that but I can't do it yeah it
doesn't grow maybe I could get like a
fake one you think that would it would
look natural yeah yeah cause I got on a
wig so why not